A review, which can also be called an inspection or
a walkthrough, is a systematic reading of a software development artifact.
Reviews can be a cost-effective way of finding defects in the artifact, and
reviews complement other verification techniques such as testing and proofs.
That is, they find, tend to find problems that the other techniques don't find.
The purpose of a review is to detect defects, which, depending on the artifact,
might be called bugs or faults.
Reviews may also be used to check adherence to corporate or
governmental standards.
Reviews should not be used to educate staff members, report status or
fix the detected problems.
Reviews can be applied to different kinds of artifacts produced during
the software development.
These include requirements documents, specifications, architectural designs,
detail designs, new code, fixes, test plans, and documentation itself.
Effective reviews are systematic.
It is not sufficent, sufficient to just have a meeting and
talk about an artifact.
People's time is expensive and group meetings are especially so.
Here are the recommended steps to take for an effective review.